[Music]
hong kong is 92 percent ethnically
chinese
but stroll through the central business
district on any given sunday and you
wouldn't know it
thousands upon thousands of domestic
helpers socialize on cardboard scattered
across parks walkways and sidewalks on
their one and only day off
55 are from the philippines and
virtually all women
a similar dynamic but for men plays out
on the high seas filipinos make up 1.4
percent of the world's population but
roughly 30 percent of the world's
shipping crew
take a cruise for instance and there's a
very good chance you'll have a filipino
made cook or server
it's not just low-skill work either
one-fifth of california-registered
nurses are from the philippines despite
comprising only four percent of its
population
on any given day 10
of all living filipinos are employed
overseas 2.3 million of which are
temporary workers
the reason may seem obvious
money
the average nurse can make 15 times more
working abroad
even domestic helpers make far more than
they would at home
but why the philippines specifically
the country is neither the world's
largest
growing nor even poorest potential
source of labor
being the cheapest is a tough
competitive advantage to maintain in a
world of 7 billion people
there will always be someone somewhere
more desperate
and yet the philippines has remained the
world's go-to source of labor for
decades almost monopolizing entire
industries
so what's the real reason
sponsored by brilliant learn math
science and computer science the
intuitive way with a link in the
description
in 1973 the middle east went on strike
cutting off the world's supply of oil
between december 1973 and january 1974
the global price of crude more than
doubled from 26 to 61 dollars per barrel
for the philippines which imported 80
percent of its oil this made a bad
situation much worse
the marco's government was already busy
fighting a communist rebellion had
declared martial law and was suffering a
balance of trade deficit when consumer
prices went through the roof and
unemployment soon followed
but the rise in oil prices had a second
unintended consequence the fundamental
transformation of the global shipping
industry
when the price of oil rose demand for
tankers fell dramatically
but because a ship ordered today is only
actually delivered years down the road
their supply continued rising long after
they were no longer needed
as you can see demand per tanker fell
for roughly the next 10 years
and during this period of excess supply
shipping became far less profitable
to cut costs companies increasingly
began registering their ships in flag of
convenience countries like panama and
liberia where they could bypass national
labor laws
unions negotiated jobs for japanese
norwegian and greek captains but the
bottom ranks were suddenly open to the
world
and who better to fill them than the
masses of recently unemployed filipinos
shipping companies didn't just get
access to a cheap willing and able
workforce fluent in english the
international language of the sea but
also their favorite kind
temporary
migrant workers are a capitalist vision
of globalization
perpetuating national borders when
convenient bypassing them when not
by importing labor from abroad you
profit from wage differentials between
countries but don't have to worry about
anti-immigrant backlash
you can hire them as soon as you have a
job to be done and fire them just as
fast when it's over with none of the
annoying paperwork
virtually all the power in this
relationship lies with the employer some
of which even take away the passports of
their workers
until march of last year for instance
domestic helpers in saudi arabia needed
their employer's permission to leave the
country
needless to say this serendipitous
combination of push in the form of
unemployment in the philippines and pole
in the form of demand for cheap labor
produced an explosion of filipino
migrant workers
in 1960 15 of all seafarers were asian
by 1987 that number had more than
quadrupled to 67 percent
the next wave came from where the first
originated the middle east
the gulf states had grand visions for
what to do with their new wealth but no
one willing to actually build their
underwater hotels and giant empty
picture frames
that's where foreign labor comes in
today 26 percent of filipino migrants
work in saudi arabia 14 in the uae 6 in
kuwait and 5 in qatar
a significant portion of the rest work
in hong kong or singapore as domestic
helpers doing the laundry child care
cooking cleaning and everything in
between for middle class households
some families even have two or three
but this is really only half the answer
to our original question
why filipinos came to dominate these
specific labor niches
50 years ago the reason was basically
coincidence timing more than anything
but even if the philippines was the
cheapest source of labor in 1970 it
hasn't remained that way for five
consecutive decades
what began as a temporary response to a
unique set of circumstances in other
words soon became a deliberate strategy
the money workers sent home called
remittances has grown from a nice side
gig to a pillar on which the entire
national economy depends
representing 10 percent of the country's
gdp
at 35 billion us dollars a year
remittances could be considered the
philippines second largest export just
behind electronics at 38 billion three
times higher than third place machinery
and 13 times larger than fourth place
copper
in the words of one former official
without these overseas jobs reducing
domestic unemployment there would be
revolution
and so to sustain this flow of cash the
philippine government has become an
unofficial broker of labor
when the president called herself the
ceo of a global philippine enterprise in
2003 she wasn't kidding
the state functions in many ways like a
corporation
one whose core business is selling one
particular commodity labor
government departments travel to trade
shows negotiate with foreign countries
and sometimes even place labor directly
it even does marketing producing posters
videos and ads reinforcing the
perception of filipinos as loyal
hardworking and docile
yet despite all this quote the state
does not promote overseas employment as
a means to sustain economic growth and
achieve national development
the government in other words is uneasy
about its participation in what some
have called legal human trafficking
it takes credit for the inflow of
remittances but no responsibility when
workers are abused
when they return home workers are
greeted as heroes not unlike members of
the military in america
sending money home is characterized as
an act of nationalism and each year the
president celebrates migrant workers day
but it's not just the government
reinforcing this system
you might think filipino migrant workers
would aggressively fight back against
these stereotypes
and some do
but many don't see themselves as being
exploited
despite high rates of abuse harassment
and harsh working conditions overseas
work is often viewed in a positive light
as an opportunity
an opportunity that's by no means
guaranteed
many see themselves as competing with
indonesians pakistanis and nepalese
reinforcing stereotypes even about
oneself is a powerful way of preserving
those limited opportunities
but more than anything else what
reinforces this outflow of labor is
economics
imagine that a bundle of cash 10 or 15
times the average local wage fell out of
the sky and into every 10th house in
your country each and every month
why would that lucky 10 percent of the
population look for a job
think about what kind of weird first
second and third order effects this
sudden airdrop of cash would have on the
economy
currency devaluation inflation lower
real incomes and greater inequality
between families receiving and not
receiving remittances
the problem with treating labor as a
resource in other words is that it leads
to the resource curse
what would these families buy with all
that money
a new car an extra room in the house or
even an extra house
perhaps the most common purchase is a
college degree
but this is not quite the escape from
poverty and investment in the nation's
future that it may appear
remittances are directly responsible for
the education of millions of young
filipinos but they're also responsible
for the lack of local demand for that
very education
the end goal of a college degree very
often is to immigrate often as a nurse
to the united states in what has been
called migrate to educate to migrate
first a mother father or both go
overseas as domestic helpers or sailors
sending whatever they can home to their
children
those children are often expected to use
that money to train as nurses immigrate
to the u.s and take their turn sending
remittances home
in 2015 more filipino nurses were
employed abroad than passed the nursing
board exams at home
until the practice was banned nursing
students were so desperate to acquire
the experience needed to go overseas
that many paid hospitals to allow them
to work
for the lucky few whose parents
sacrificed their labor abroad who
themselves studied for years and years
and years acquiring degrees and who have
the incredible luck of entering the
labor market at the right moment
this is a powerful pathway to a better
life for their families back home
but think about what's really happening
here
individuals are expected to work
overseas just to pay for an education
for the chance of leaving giving them
the privilege of supporting their
families
the state may take credit for this
system but for their families these
individual moms dads uncles and aunts
are fulfilling the role of the state
providing basic things like food and
education
and because it relies on an immense
amount of hard work sacrifice and luck
this is not a sustainable equitable
process
it can't really be scaled or
systematized and it relies on an
increasingly tenuous assumption that
their labor and skills are appreciated
and welcome abroad
all it takes is a change of visa rules
in a foreign country or a pandemic to
nullify all those years of sacrifice
last year for instance the philippine
government capped the number of nurses
allowed to work overseas forcing all but
5 000 to stay home
risking their lives for very little
money
so what do they do
many go back to school in hopes that a
second to a third degree will make them
more competitive
according to one study 39 percent of
working filipinos are over-educated for
their jobs yet a quarter are
under-educated
this is just one more way the
traditional system of education fails
students
by preparing them for jobs that no
longer exist
learning should be flexible interesting
and based on practical universal skills
like problem solving logic and math all
things which today's sponsor brilliant
was designed to be brilliant has courses
on everything from programming to
problem solving physics and calculus
what i like about brilliant is that it
makes learning fun by focusing on
applying knowledge through interactive
puzzles riddles and games not just by
rote memorizing facts
one trick i recently learned is to start
your day by doing something small but
productive
doing a quick lesson or challenge on
brilliant in the morning is a great way
to instantly feel accomplished learn
something new and start your day on the
right foot
click the link on screen now and the
first 200 people will get 20 off their
annual premium subscription you can even
gift a subscription to a friend or
family member
go pick what interests you most and
start learning today